[Music]
in 2015 if you were in Minnesota going
in to get your regular teeth cleaning at
River Bluff dental you would have
encountered a bizarre unsettling scene
these are just some of the signs that
vandalized an abandoned dentist's office
the reason Walter Palmer a dentist
working there had gotten into deep
trouble for trophy hunting in Africa but
Walter's problem wasn't with the law he
had the correct hunting permits his
business was in shambles because he had
killed Cecil the lion and the story had
gone viral an outraged internet mob
quickly rallied determined to make
Walter pay he is just disgusting he is
despicable poor Cecil I mean he's
despicable he's Facebook groups were set
up to coordinate his disgrace his
business practice was forced to shut
down public threats like this were
everywhere his private address was
leaked online his house was graffiti'd
and pigs feet or thrown on his driveway
even now four years later it haunts him
at his dental practice Walter Palmer has
been publicly shamed public shaming is
an old phenomenon given new life by
social media
bringing back everything but the stalks
and literal tomatoes the term shaming is
an understatement
too since these often have tangible
impact loss of income job being outcast
from the public and sometimes these
effects can feel deserved but there are
also times when the crime and level of
outrage field mismatched actions ranging
from the absolutely heinous to
decade-old bad jokes feel like they get
the same level of coverage online
Twitter goes on and on until someone is
fired or canceled your reputation can be
destroyed in an instant so I wanted to
ask why has public shaming become so
popular and is it making the world a
better place or is it more harm than
good for a great deal of human history
people lived in small communities where
public punishment and shaming was common
if you are caught stealing you might get
ten lashings at the center of town and
these public punishments helped
reinforce social norms both for the
criminal
and the onlookers the criminal was
shamed in front of a crowd that knew him
and the onlooking community would think
I never want that to happen to me but
despite this dual benefit to society
this public justice slowly fell out of
fashion around the early 20th century a
common explanation for this is that as
people move to densely populated cities
shaming loses its stink because if
you're ever seriously shamed you can
just disappear into another crowd within
your city the threat of public shaming
just isn't as motivating but this
landscape completely changed with the
rise of the internet suddenly we're all
placed back in the same small village
again because our digital footprint
follows us everywhere New York or New
Hampshire you're always searchable and
your internet skin is are a click away
now of course some things have changed
you won't literally be whipped during
your shaming we've done away with
corporal punishment so that's good but
in some ways the way we publicly shame
is more brutal than our ancestors
because our new internet mobs cannot
forgive consider that in the past the
public mob might gather in the street
for an hour the wit man whipped ten
times and it was over the criminal had
literally taken their licks and then the
person could be reintegrated back into
society but today the public mob gathers
on Twitter's for days for months we all
take a crack with no one counting
without even a number to count towards
there is no leader to an outraged
collective which means nobody can say
when it's over because no one of us
speaks for all of us our forgiveness is
fragmented so as long as someone is
willing to continue the public shaming
it will continue but it doesn't end
there modern shavings are also brutal
because they are impersonal just words
on a screen we don't know the person
we're trashing online whereas before you
knew who you were publicly humiliating
maybe he was your neighbor caught in
adultery maybe she was your teacher
caught stealing you knew the person and
had to face that that's an emotional
moment
you can't ignore what you're doing to
that person but now we can say anything
and feel nothing there's no need to look
back at our shame ease no requirement to
see the tears in their eyes Monica
Lewinsky a name is almost synonymous
with shame disgust
is what it was like to be one of the
first recipients of this new global
shaming culture overnight I went from
being a completely private figure to a
publicly humiliated one worldwide not a
day goes by that I'm not reminded of my
mistake and I get it it was easy to
forget that that woman was dimensional
had a soul and was once unbroken but
even despite all of this even though
shaming often go off the rails I
understand why we love them they're a
modern form of vigilantism public
shaming promised us the chance for
justice even when our legal system fails
or is too slow you can see this with the
me2 movement that has brought people to
justice who are previously thought
untouchable due to their influence
public shaming also promised to
establish the social norms and behavior
we want even if our city doesn't have
politicians who are willing to stand up
for that but beyond the gleeful shouts
of justice and pointing fingers there's
a dark side to mob justice for one thing
power is a slippery thing in a mob what
can start as harmless criticism of a
wealthy trophy hunter can quickly
snowball into something else when you've
got thousands of people behind you and
the person you're shaming has lost their
job their income their personal privacy
and everything they've worked for you're
not punching up anymore
you're kicking a guy while he's down
secondly when there's no due process
mistakes are made like when the Internet
mob went after Sunil Tripathi and his
family because they suspected him of
being the Boston Marathon bomber we
publicly shamed and harassed them only
to find out he had committed suicide
days before the attack even happened
so instead of being heroes and catching
the bad guy like we thought the Internet
mob had only been attacking a grieving
family and the final problem is mob
mentality when the mob aims itself up
there's no new ones whether they've
stolen a cat car or kilt azar there's
only one option and that's beat them up
also known as the Batman approach no one
knows this better than Tyler Clementi an
18 year old kid who is harassed online
after an intimate video of him was
leaked online three days later he jumped
from the George Washington Bridge
public shaming in some ways represents
the best and worst of us
it represents our collective desire for
true justice but also our brutal
short-sighted and often unforgiving mob
mentality continuing a culture of public
shaming guarantees many more people will
be brought to judgment but it will
likely be a mix of justice and life
destroying Internet overreactions and
that's not a trade-off we should be ok
with anything that risks the innocent
just to catch a few more bad guys isn't
worth it this is a philosophy deeply
rooted in our justice system and it's
why prosecuting criminals is slow and
tedious we have to make sure someone is
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt and we
do all of this because we found out a
long time ago in a world where we shoot
first and ask questions later it isn't
just the criminal that has to be worried
everyone should be scared
[Music]
thanks for watching that video we're
gonna talk more about public shaming but
first I want to tell you about our
sponsor today - Lane
- Lane is a password manager something
that is essential in the 21st century
you're always visiting new websites or
getting apps that require you to create
accounts and there's a catch-22 if you
want to remember your login you can only
reuse a few variants of the same
passwords over and over again meaning
that if one website is hacked they've
essentially hacked all your accounts of
course the solution is having completely
different passwords for every single
website you visit but but then it's easy
to forget your many different passwords
- leme solve this by managing all your
passwords for you across all your
devices not just on chrome but not on
Safari not just on Firefox but not on
your Android across all of them which
means you can trust - lean to
automatically create strong passwords
for you truly random passwords and never
have to worry about forgetting that
password or worry about getting on a
device you didn't save that password on
it's a great combination of two things
helping with your security but also just
being more convenient it also has neat
autofill features so that you never have
to remember your wallet or waste time
filling in personal information when
you're on
and the absolute best part is that you
can get dashlane for free by going to -
lang comm slash coffee break and if you
want even more protection you can get
10% off their premium membership by
using promo code coffee break their
premium membership gives you access to
dark web monitoring which checks to see
if your personal information is being
bought and sold on the dark web for even
more internet protection so once again
whether you want a free membership or a
premium membership - Lang comm slash
coffee break it supports the show and
you're going to love it okay so real
quick let's wrap up this shaming idea to
books that I can really recommend are so
you've been publicly shamed by Jon
Ronson and is shame really necessary by
Jennifer jockette in a way these books
are meant for each other one kind of
parallels the other Jon Ronson talks
about kind of the problems with shaming
and Jennifer jockette examines some of
those pitfalls but also the good sides
of shaming I love both of these books
and agree with each of them on different
points with Ronson I I think he got gave
a really beautifully honest portrayal of
how brutal these shaming can be but I
think his hypothesis of why shaming is
died out is kind of is just wrong he
says instead of it being because people
can move to cities it's rather because
we just realized how brutal they were
and I think he conflates their public
shaming and just corporal punishment in
general which there was like some
distancing from corporal punishment but
that's kind of a separate issue from
shaming and then as far as Jennifer
Crockett she properly identifies the
fact that shame is the way we set up
social norms it's how we orient
ourselves is with the approval and
disapproval of other people so that
social norm idea is really crucial but I
think she's too optimistic with how
empathetic we can be online and I think
if you look at the reward structure of
these sites I don't think it promotes
that I think it benefits all the worst
excesses of our you know ability to
mobilize as a mob and I don't think her
kind of utopian idea of how I could use
shame is really gonna pan out
in the 21st century unless something
majorly changes that's all for now once
again thank you for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]